[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth new work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships the
one on openly Jade warshaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today open
phones here at triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in we
will talk about you right in front of
you Kathy is going to start us off today
Kathy's over in Austin Texas hi Kathy
how are you
great thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
so I've heard you all advise against
using credit cards in favor of debit
cards or cash so my question is why
shouldn't my husband and I take
advantage of getting credit card points
for travel expenses that are required
for work but are going to be reimbursed
by the employer
so your employer is so poor they require
you to advance them for your own travel
no sir
well why do they require you to advance
them for their own for your own travel
you're traveling on behalf of an
employer and they're not paying for it
in advance why are they making you pay
for it for them
well that's that's the established
protocol uh
yeah
why
I don't know we haven't asked them yeah
so you understand that if they decide
not to pay you one month that those are
your credit cards
that's true and you understand that I'm
the guy that's been counseling and
coaching people for 35 years so I'm the
guy that had the guy walk in with eleven
thousand dollars on his Amex That was
supposed to be reimbursed but when he
went to the office that day there was a
padlock on the door and they'd filed
chapter 11 he got NADA he had eleven
thousand dollars on his Amex Amex didn't
care if his company had gone broke they
wanted their money
understand
them hmm it's kind of a problem isn't it
for him after
absolutely for you why are you different
well we haven't we haven't experienced
that same situation that you just
decided I know but you're exposed to
that exact same risk
this is true and all for an airline mile
it's almost impossible to use
so I I think if you're gonna you know if
you're willing to take that risk I'd be
very scared about it a lot it is
standard in Corporate America somehow
Corporate America has conned its
employee base into taking a loan on
their behalf
with the promise of repayment
um and taking the risk for that and
acting like it's not no big deal but it
is it's a real deal I've noticed it many
many times going sideways on people the
other thing people do is they run up
stuff on their credit card uh because
they're just not watching this not
reimbursable and so they end up with a
reimbursement check that's less than a
balance that's right yeah you could you
could spend on that credit card and
think oh I'll get reimbursed for this
but Becky down in accounting might not
think so
you're on the hook for that but you got
an airline mile but you got your airline
mile
and when you use a debit card the
strangest thing happens you pay more
attention because it's like real money
so here's the deal Kathy couple things
number one when you use a credit card
you are likely to spend it to spend more
than when you use a debit card period
tons of research showing that because it
it doesn't have the same friction that
marketers call it in your brain a lot
more so your chances of spending more
are higher where you're doing it on
behalf of an employer hoping for
reimbursement your chances of making a
mistake are higher obviously you don't
think that any of this applies to you
but it does it does and so you're just
more susceptible to risk and to problems
uh and then the third thing is this
and I think the most compelling argument
is this
I have never met a single millionaire
this is Dave you know
I made it all on my airline miles
[Laughter]
that was my breakthrough my financial
difference the Difference Maker in my
financial plan was I took a billion
dollar company that studies consumer
behavior in depth and I was smarter than
them I whipped them I didn't spend more
and I got airline miles and I actually
used the airline miles I actually gamed
the system and I became a millionaire
because of it never met one not in 30
years of doing this well let me take it
a step further I know a lot of middle
class broke people who think they're
gaming the system and are walking
strutting around acting like they got
something with an airline mile but they
really didn't at the end of the day I'll
take it a step further Dave I don't like
supporting companies that their entire
uh model for having revenue is built on
failure
failure to pay failure to pay on time I
don't like that I like companies that
offer a service that really would like
to help you and they get revenue from
giving you something or helping you do
something or giving you a service I I
can't support a company where the only
way they make money is by people failing
to pay failing to pay on time that's
that's the the top seller right there I
don't like the way they get them in the
churn
is they offer an airline Mile and oh by
the way Consumer Reports says 78 percent
of the airline miles are never redeemed
so I know Kathy's may be in the 22
percent but and she may get 100
reimbursement she may never overspend
but you are playing with snakes Kathy
look everybody says I pay my
dollars
in credit card debt so somebody's lying
yeah and it's up right now yeah and
somebody's you know and I got to tell
you the number of people that we've
coached out of credit card debt over the
years that said it you know it all
started because I was trying to get a
free airline ticket mm-hmm and and
here's the other one this one's humorous
to me this is not Kathy didn't bring
this up but we'll just keep on this
subject for a minute
um the Discover points you get you get
two you get two points back yeah so you
get two percent two percent so here's
the deal you spend a hundred dollars to
get two dollars
now explain to me how that causes wealth
uh
that you in order to get two dollars you
spend a hundred yeah what math class did
you people go to
the school of the broke yeah I'm telling
you it's that that's the kind of stuff
that's out there and so what I studied
and the way we came up with the process
that we use here is
common sense that Grandma had
and I studied where companies are being
predatory and I stay away from snakes
and I studied wealthy people and I find
out what wealthy people do yep and yes
some wealthy people Kathy do have a
credit card and some of them do pay it
off every month
but none of them claim that that was
somehow a financial breakthrough that's
right and and you're already spending
more mental calories on this than it's
worth even if you're getting full
redistribution on this so
you ask why that's why you spend more
you're more likely on a travel expense
account to spend money that's not
reimbursable because oh I get Maryland
Moss back oh I buy I'll buy two instead
of three I'll buy three instead of two
because I get my Airline on this back
um and uh so you're more likely to spend
more you're higher risk when you are
loaning this Corporate America
characters your money hoping they're
going to pay you back each month
scary stuff
and we have seen the times that they
didn't you can't just assume assuming
they'll get you in trouble you know what
they say about it yeah I've heard this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us netsuite worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34
thousand customers who trust netsuite to
help make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America I opened phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Nikki
is in Montgomery Alabama hi Nikki
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up
okay we have just recently found out
that my husband's boss is actively
trying to sell the company
um we're the only ones in the company
that know this right now simply because
my husband's kind of the financial guy
who was going to be the one to gather
all that financial information to
potential buyers
so we do have a heads up which is a
blessing
um he the boss has also indicated that
we would be getting a severance of about
200 000 of course taxes will have to
come out of that
my question is after taxes
how should we manage this knowing we're
going into a season likely of no income
well if you know that you're going into
a season of likely no income can you
prepare on the front end so that you
don't have a season of likely no income
well with him being the financial person
of the of the company we just kind of
feel like it's the right thing to do
um to stay until the last day I'm not
suggesting not staying necessarily go
ahead and have a job lined up after the
last day you start the next day well we
have started looking
um we just we don't know if this will be
in 60 days or six months we're just not
sure yet on on that we're gonna go ahead
and get some you can get some leads in
the pipeline that you tighten up as you
do know
right and we're working on that he's
already had
um a few interviews
um that's been real substantial yet but
he has had a few interviews so he's the
CFO
right he is and how large a company
[Music]
sure
oakers who are kind of I guess the
middleman on trying to get this sale
completed or we're in the very
beginnings of it but in the we're
these Brokers have indicated this would
be you know tens of millions of dollars
yeah okay so um so they've got they've
got how many employees
um
my guess is probably 250 to 300. do you
think he'll fire all of them
um I don't know okay we don't really
know how
well in order for me to stay if I'm your
husband
you're going you're you're going to have
to sit down with it you need to sit down
with his boss tomorrow and just say you
know I'm willing to stay with you and
help you complete this transaction like
we've been talking about but my only
requirement is that you put the
severance package in writing
in order to do that and that you keep an
open line of communication with me so
that I have good timing issues so I can
line up my next thing to you know to
line up with this if I if you surprise
me since you're not telling anybody else
and you decide you're not going to tell
me something and I get surprised I'm
going to leave you with this
my obligation I totally agree with that
I mean what would be his obligation to
him goes away if he's not willing to a
put the severance in writing B put a
promise to an open line and perform to
an open line of continuous communication
about timing and probability and
whatever we're not asking for any of the
10 million we're not asking for any of
that that's not yours that's his he owns
it but he does owe you if you're gonna
if your husband's gonna stick with him
he does owe him communication and the
severance in writing otherwise I'm gonna
go ahead and leave now yeah because
where's the negative side of his boss
doing that for him I mean I can't think
there's no downside if he's really going
to do it all
right okay but this guy is secretive and
doesn't want to tell anybody and
um
you know I I you don't need to blow off
all your customers and all your
employees I agree with that but he's
really really holding this close I mean
the the phrase that scared me Nikki is
when you said the only reason we found
out
was because he needed my husband's help
meaning that this guy really isn't
discussing this with his senior
leadership team and he really owes them
a discussion
right that that's how I'm interpreting
that is that he needed he needed my
husband yeah otherwise you would have
known nothing otherwise you wouldn't
know nothing yeah so the other senior
people are going to be hung out hide and
dry that's what you're telling me wow
and so that scares me dealing with this
guy this guy's he's hardcore so I'm
going to be a little hardcore back and
just go you're going to communicate with
me and you're going to put the severance
package in writing and then you can keep
working the interviews and and line up
something where you start the next day
and the 200 000 severance package
actually becomes a signing bonus then
there's extra money
should we get this this 200 000 of
course less axes how do you think we
should manage that if you have a new job
that's equal you just throw it on the
baby steps Wherever You Are
uh we have just a tiny mortgage
um like 40 Grand on our mortgage okay
would you say hang on to that or if if
you have the new job I'd pay off the
mortgage of the day you got the
severance okay but if you don't then I'm
gonna hold on to cash like crazy until
we land the new job and then I'm going
to pay off the mortgage and and do some
investing and some generosity and some
enjoyment after going through the stress
of this he may want to go you guys may
want to go on a really nice high-end
cruise for two weeks and you should oh
yeah that sounds great
can I go too yeah that's great I'm not
talking about the Walmart on the season
no no no good stuff okay good stuff Yes
sounds good to me hey thanks for calling
in Nikki good stuff uh Hunter is in
Houston Texas hey Hunter what's up
uh Dave and Jade how y'all doing better
than we deserve sir how can we help
yeah I am uh 26 years old uh exploring a
uh a company change in the residential
construction field uh it would be good
for the debt paying off but I'm not sure
if it's a great move for the career but
you want to go on with why would it be a
bad move for the career
the current company I work for is a
high-end uh Custom Construction uh
residential homes
um totaling 63 000 take home uh I have
no benefit
um and uh except the gas car that saves
me six thousand annually uh I just
received a five percent raise last week
after 10 months of the company because
I'm still underpaid for my industry
um due to this I picked up a side hustle
giving me an extra 8 500 annually all in
uh I'm about 77. what's the new guy
The New Guy The Fortune 500 company
offering 90 to 95 000 base plus uh bonus
that's not a good career move why
it's not a good I I my gut tells me uh
sir I'm building three Custom Homes
totaling out to 11 million dollars and
uh something tells me if I'm busting my
butt in front of uh people that can
afford this kind of stuff when it's my
turn to start my own company I might
just land in the right right right
Network
nah
you don't think so no
you're 26.
yes sir nobody's hiring you to build a
eight million dollar house
you're right sorry I don't mean to be
mean but
that's okay I'm just being truthful
um I like you I think you're a sharp guy
um and uh but you know I'm thinking you
know in in five years maybe but in five
years you've lost two hundred thousand
dollars of income not working for these
other folks
correct you know and you stated to me
that even after a five percent raise
you're still underpaid by the industry
it's disturbing
why would they do that
yes sir something there's something
bothering you about your current company
and it's because because of the
statement they're making by underpaying
and it feels like you know they know
they're underpaying
is that right
yes sir
yeah I I'm
that's not if there's other reasons to
not change maybe but I think I'd go
ahead and take the other gig you got
plenty of time to become a custom
builder and you'll build up your own
network but working for free or cheap
and somebody taking advantage of you is
what you're talking about that doesn't
sound appealing to me
nope I'm walking this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hollow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today we have
people who tune into every episode of
the Ramsay show they can answer all the
questions and they're still stressed out
and stuck why
because knowing what to do with your
money isn't the problem
you have to actually do it personal
finance is 80 Behavior it's only 20 head
knowledge I know
I'm not supposed to eat donuts but if I
eat them anyway The Knowing doesn't
matter
see it's the behavior change that gives
you the results and The Proven way to
get this is with Financial Peace
University it's no help with the donuts
but it'll help with the budget and the
getting out of debt I promise you the
class is the difference between trying
to get in shape and just thinking about
it and reading books about it or
actually getting a personal trainer and
an appointment at the gym to do the work
that's why this class has worked for 10
million people and after nine weeks and
nine lessons and being with this
superhero called a coordinator that will
love you enough to tell you the truth
and encourage you
you'll make progress faster than you
ever have in your life and I know you
think you already know it all
you do
but you're not doing it
common sense is always been around
but I still helped 10 million people
implement the common sense with
Financial Peace University I can get all
the Ramsay stuff in a book yeah you sure
can
you can
but I can promise you the people that go
through Financial Peace University have
a much higher probability of becoming
millionaires than those that buy a book
and put it on their coffee table and use
it as a coaster
and that's what happens a lot so don't
just listen to the show and say I
already don't go you got to go do this
stuff jump into Financial Peace
University
ramseysolutions.com FPU
ramsesolutions.com FPU hey if you're
enjoying this show and you want to help
us out follow us subscribe click the
follow button the Subscribe button click
the share button share the show share a
link of the show the podcast the YouTube
uh tell people where we're you're
watching us on TBN and what time or your
local radio station wherever you're
consuming the show let people know about
it and that helps all of us
um and since you are our marketing plan
we need your help thank you very much
Todd is with us Todd is in Miami hi Todd
welcome to the Ramsay show
hello Dave thank you for uh taking my
call sure what's up uh
a problem with uh parents saying no to
parents
uh
but as long as uh take a monster I
feature I did your course I did it back
in 2016. it was hard it's one of the
worst things I went to I didn't even
know I was in debt so I want to thank
you for that sure
I've built up a nice little
question
I mean some income properties they
didn't have everything cooked in the
crock pot get everything else supposed
to do you know uh and my mother's
husband passed no life insurance
knowing that they were there together
for 30 years now
she's in my hands because I took my you
know the southern skin tape can't do
anything
so she wants a nice condo or get it I'm
I have a real estate license also so it
was kind of easy but it wasn't easy
because you have to put 20 down
who has to put 20 down
you we did yes we did
well I bought it for her but I put my
name on the team okay so you bought a
condo for your mom to live in why why
couldn't she live in our room
she didn't that's what she wanted
how old are you
52. that's what she wanted
oh yeah well I don't care what she wants
and why are you saying it like
if she says it that's what it is like 52
years old
yeah how old is Mom
75 in good health yeah and and she has
absolutely no money
okay well this is
what I thought automatically you had
some kind of policy I just
the way they were going and the
Christmases and the things
she have any money
well she has two pensions and Social
Security but it's not enough to cover
the extensions they just went up on HOA
fees over there
the six months in reserve so that's like
six thousand dollars so
uh and I want my kitchen done and I want
the the success I said so wait that's
your mom talking that's your mom talking
you hear him yeah
I bought the book I just told your
producer the guys I read the book two
times and I'm struggling I said no
yesterday which book
uh boundaries oh yeah okay yeah so so
the answer is no
to all of these things you guys start
learning how to say no
yeah so how much I'm not getting much
phone calls or anything I don't care how
much is the condo payment
it was a uh the condo the monthly
payment
uh 972 okay and she's supposed to be
paying that
right and she has two pensions and
Social Security so she can pay a 900
payment
right right okay
but there's no but
I know the only button I'm looking for
this one yeah I I want to know you doing
this for your mom what's the implication
financially for you
well my question is keeping you from
down substantially uh I wanted to buy
some more income properties because I
want to retire I work in construction
and I don't want to be you know uh I'm
doing things to to to change my whole
career
what's your net worth Todd
my network uh gets the two properties
I have about two hundred thousand
dollars Equity one
not about now what fifty thousand
dollars in savings
I have a small pension from a government
a couple of government jobs I have yeah
what do you make a year
about 125. you do not have the money to
help your mother any further I know I
know you don't have enough money you
didn't call me up with a 10 million
dollar net worth if it was chump change
and you wanted to go fix the kitchen
fine
but but she's basically completely out
of control emotionally and I don't know
where you got or she got the idea that
you're obligated to give her a condo and
fix the kitchen and and and and and and
now when people don't respect boundaries
and Henry Cloud talks about in the book
boundaries and then you set a boundary
please don't expect them to accept it
graciously so I suspect her little
spoiled self's pretty pissed off at you
oh well
I know that's right I'm sorry I'm back
on when you said and she want she said
she needs a nice you know is almost
making these demands on you have you
said to her mom I I you know I'm doing
the best I can with my money I I want to
help you get set up turn into a condo
yeah you can afford it yeah and if you
can't live with that then uh I guess
you'll need to move and I'll show the
condo but I'm well I'm willing to let
you live here I've already done this
much and I I just can't do any more and
yeah I can't I can't no you really can't
you don't have any money you don't have
enough money
I mean you don't have enough money it's
a math thing and so you you don't make
six hundred thousand dollars a year and
have 10 million dollars it's not that's
not your numbers so and you you you know
the reason you called here is you know
she's weird and out of control right
I know yeah
yeah I mean she's your mom I'm sorry to
say that but I mean that what she's
doing is whacked so you just gotta smile
and go nah
huh done all I can do sorry Mom love you
but not doing any more my love does not
my love for you does not indicate that I
have to be out of control nor am I at an
age or a net worth where I take orders
from people are you the only kid Todd it
no but I'm the go-to okay you're The
Golden Child the whole family and I've
got I said no like three times this year
and uh I don't get any more phone calls
that's all right you know keep saying no
it's good practice yeah you just got to
build your muscle and she'll figure it
out eventually she'll understand that no
actually means no it's a complete
sentence
I have I'm sorry honey yes it's hard
when it's your mom but she's she's been
whacked dude yeah she's out of control
whack this is a Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America we're talking
about your life and your money it is a
free call Triple eight eight two five
five two two five Stephen is in New
Orleans hi Stephen how can we help
yes my uh wife and I are
navigating a family tragedy and have
recently gotten a reasonable check
to deal with as well and I was hoping to
get an outside opinion on what we should
do with it
okay tell us what's going on
the check is from a two-year battle over
homeowners insurance claim a couple of
large hurricanes came through Louisiana
and damaged our home and it's a seventy
thousand dollar check we have very
little debt
and uh two months ago our five-year-old
son died
and it's uh
very it's difficult to know
what to do it's difficult to breathe
um yeah what happened to your son huh
myself born with a series of heart
defects he had to have an open heart
surgery when he was five months old
and had to have a second one last
October that we knew was coming
and it was supposed to last for we were
hoping for decades
but unfortunately after the surgery he
his heart function took a dive
and we got him on the
heart transplant list
but
he didn't make it that long I'm so sorry
I fought a long time didn't he
wow uh he was in the ICU for five months
and yeah he uh yeah
what was his name
James Edward Cochran James
no King Kane okay okay
wow wow Stephen I'm so sorry
um also I can't even imagine
you know I can't breathe and it's and I
and I just met you a minute ago I can't
even imagine being in your Old Situation
um what I tell folks to do and this is
from Decades of doing this is anytime
you're in a situation where there's
um a tragedy
the loss of a loved one primarily try
not to make any big decisions while you
can't breathe
and um
you'll you will uh your memories will
always be there and the pain will always
be there but your mind will clear
over the coming months the fog will
start to lift and right now you're just
walking along and you see something or
you hear something and it activates and
a wave hits you right now is that right
uh that's exactly right yeah that'll
happen less and less and less and it's
not because you're going to forget him
that's we don't we don't want anybody to
do that it's just because you're
managing through the grief process and
um but no one is thinking no one if Dr
John deloney has two phds and one of
them is in counseling where he facing
this he would not be thinking clearly it
would it takes the best of minds and
brains and puts a fog on them to go
through what you all are going through
so we always tell folks if you can
try doing nothing
with it that is a big money expense so
for instance if someone calls and uh had
a lady called the other day had been
married 50 years and her husband passed
away and she got a six hundred thousand
dollar life insurance check and she said
what do we do I said well it's been two
weeks you're not doing anything I want
you to park this in a high-yield savings
account and then six months from now
when you can start to breathe a little
bit better your mind will be a little
bit clearer we can talk about it or even
a year from now and so if you don't need
it sounds like you don't have any debt
you said except a little bit and
on the house and and I'm sure you guys
are zombie mode robot mode whatever you
call it going back to work trying to
reach you know restart lives and are you
back to work or are you still out
my well I quit my job uh two years ago
and got back in school and our plan was
that I would stay home with him and do
school while my wife worked
and
this has left me I I am still not
working the prospect of
trying to go out and find a job and meet
people
um
usually someday some days that it sounds
okay most days
I
I can't do that yeah
a little bit different she still works
she was kind of established at her job
so she she finds a little bit of Solace
going in when she can sure when she
wants to well I would be working with
someone to help me walk through the
grief
and they can help you figure out the
timing of plugging back in because
there's a positive element to plugging
back in it's not punishment
and it's not disrespectful
to your son to go on and have a life
um uh and so you're going to do that and
you're going to do that in reasonable
timing and you're gonna do that but in
the meantime if you guys can make your
bills and I guess you can off of your
wife's income I'm gonna just take the
70k and park it in a CD for six months
and just cry for six months and get
through the get through the worst of
this and yeah get your new
your new reality the new career saddle
and climb into it and you know I I got
to tell you January is going to look a
lot different than June
yeah it is it is and again it's not the
disrespecting your son his memory uh by
any stretch of the imagination but
um but the best thing you can do is to
be healthy
and to walk the path to get healthy and
to part of that's being plugged back in
and so if you're working she's working
we're working a plan we're looking back
into the future again we're not living
in a dark cloud in January uh or less of
a Dark Cloud then you're going to make
much better decisions so try not to do
anything with big money or big money
decisions for six months at least I like
a year but at least to six months and um
but you know I'm so sorry man I can't
even imagine but I am going to encourage
you to lean into
the grieving process and maybe even get
somebody to talk to about that it won't
hurt anything at all
because as bad as it sucks the only
thing that sucks worse is for you to
still be sitting exactly the same place
six months from now
and that's not okay
uh for you I want I want you to have a
better life than that and uh but boy I I
can't imagine how sad
um I just can't get my head around it
hey thanks for the call if we can help
further Stephen you call us anytime
we're here for you
there's a uh
an element
Jade that we talk about here all the
time for The Listener out there to the
us talking to Stephen they're listening
in 20 million plus of them
um
anytime you're in a trauma situation
the brain shuts down
Dr deloney talks about this and he does
like for instance during covid we had Dr
deloney on every day telling people okay
you're in a weird situation a whole
bunch of people are freaking out you
remember how nasty people got during
code they were mean man they were scared
going off because your brain shuts down
all the critical thinking skills when
you're in trauma it floods the chemicals
over the critic so if you're standing in
the middle of the interstate and you
hear Ma and there's a horn coming at you
you're like God I'm about to die with an
18-wheeler your brain does not have time
to say well let's discuss what will
happen if the 18 wheeler which is weighs
a whole lot more continues to come at 74
miles an hour and impacts your body of
160 pounds what will this what will the
physics of that be your brain does not
have time to do that so your brain
naturally shuts down in a traumatic
situation and says get out
and your most primitive part kicks in
the lizard brainly calm and so anytime
you're in trauma you don't make big
decisions because your lizard brain is
making the decisions your critical
thinking skills are shut off
so don't make big decisions in those
situations and we all have different
things that cause that to happen to our
brain this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show we help people build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships open phones here
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five thank you for joining us
America Jade wash all Ramsay personality
is my co-host today thank you for being
here America triple eight eight two five
five two two five Craig's in Nashville
hi Craig welcome to the Ramsay show
hey thanks for having me sure what's up
so
I'm soon to be married to my fiance and
we are both young I'm 21 she's 23. we
both have
well-established jobs I make roughly 30
an hour now I'm expected to go to 35 in
the next year
she makes 27 and of course she can go
higher in the next few years we're both
very early in our careers
and my fiance is she has over 250 000 in
liquid cash
um
she has ten thousand dollars in debt
um I have roughly 60 I've bought Seven
Acres that I still have 60 on I guess we
do plan on building a house so I guess
what I'm wondering is
do we spend that money on the house and
basically live mortgage free or should
we invest that money in something else
wow where'd she get 250 000 cash at 21
years old
well she her father died when she was 10
and her parents were divorced at the
time so she was the sole Heir so
everything that he owned did go to her
of course she couldn't take the rest of
it until she turned 18. she has recently
sold the property and she has this money
what do you do for a living
I'm an electrician for Nashville what
does she do
she is a dental assistant with expanded
functions phenomenal when do you guys
get married
um next year 2024.
yes 24. why the delay
um
planning really I mean she she's she's
always dreamed of the biggest you know
Princess
um over the top wedding not that not
that we'll spend a ridiculous amount of
money on the wedding it's just
especially booking venues nowadays I
mean you're a year out from you call
today you're at least a year out from
today for a lot of places who's paying
um her parents will front the majority
of the money not that we won't lean on
some of our money but we don't plan on
paying for the wedding ourselves and the
budget the budget out of your pocket
will be about what do you think
uh I don't imagine it being over five to
ten thousand dollars have you had this
discussion with her
with her I don't really care what you
imagine I was asking what the real
budget is yeah well I mean
yeah because that enters into the
discussion of this 250. I mean if you're
going to spend 100 on a wedding on you
need to know that you know yeah
absolutely not I know
I heard what you said I also heard that
the prince super Princess wants a 18
months to plan a wedding that's off the
chart and I don't you don't get those
for 10K
yeah so I don't know what we're doing I
guess you can you but you guys need to
know what you're doing you do now in the
meantime if you know you're over a year
out from this can you get your debt
cleaned up in that time or a good
portion of it I think I I could probably
get 10 of mine cleaned up I have 10.
yes I have part of that 60 I have
roughly 10 in this miscellaneous
personal loans I got a boat loan and I
got a car loan and no both of them are
under five thousand dollars yeah under
it yeah but why do you feel like over
the course of a year and a half you'll
only pay off ten thousand dollars
um making 30 an hour
yeah
um that's true I could do better I think
you can yeah it's pretty wimpy I think
you can I mean you're making thirty
dollars look if it were me if I were you
I would my goal would be I am gonna do
whatever it takes to clear the majority
of this debt in the next year and a half
working extra picking up extra hours
doing whatever I have to do to clear
that out then you can kind of come in
she's got the money to clear out her
debt and then you guys can come in you
live in an apartment
no sir we both live with our parents
still okay all right
um so my suggestion would be you both
become debt free you have a wedding
budget that is under control and then
you begin to think about and dream about
building a house for cash on this
property
okay yes I would do that I would not
break ground on the new house before one
your one year anniversary
that would be the soonest which means
after you get married you're gonna run
an apartment for a year or something for
a year yeah okay because it takes a year
of marriage to know how close to your
mother-in-law to build and yeah and
honestly you guys you you building a
house is stressful
for people that have done it before
building a house is stressful for people
that are old and experienced building a
house is stressful for people that have
been married for 10 years and really
know each other you got one year of
marriage you're 21 at that point you're
22 and 24.
um it's and now you're drawing a house
you're getting the architecture work
done you're coming into agreement on all
of that you're asking for a real tough
project
because everything is so new in your
life so um well let me ask you a
question Dave would you suggest for a
person's first time home buyer would you
suggest it to be a first time build no
I I feel like I wouldn't I'd want to get
it I know you're going to rent for a
little while but I feel like starting
out home ownership with with a new build
just feels it's very hard it's very hard
you're asking for trouble and so yeah I
I would not recommend it if you're gonna
do it wait at least a year because
you're gonna you're gonna face some
relationship trials as you go through
this it's a hundred percent sure and
I've been married 41 years we have been
we have built three houses together
we've gone broke and built a business
that brings in 300 million a year and
we've done all of that and we're in the
middle of building a house right now and
we have to be very careful about how we
talk to each other
[Laughter]
it's a hillbilly fight when you have a
discussion over the stove or you have a
discussion over the roof color or you
have a you know uh what's your design
style Dave it's um
um efficient and
um yeah and Sharon actually has style
and so that always conflicts that that's
that's a battle right always a conflict
so sorry Sharon yeah but I mean hey
we've been doing it a long time together
we set you know we sit down together we
say we're going to do this we're going
to treat each other nice all the way
through and we generally do yeah we
generally do but we're and we're
experienced I mean we're really good at
it yeah and uh I'm telling you and and
so it's not our first ride on the
Cabbage truck you know so uh the first
question is the first question how much
no good no no don't have to be now
that's good it does if you only got 250
yeah yeah if that's all you got to build
you got to ask how much you gotta ask a
lot of how much because that's a that's
a tight build what's your first question
uh mine yeah I want to see what she
wants and then I also want to make sure
that it's serving the overall purpose
and fits in the whole project and uh it
sounds like how much yeah well it does
it it does that's part of it but can it
be delivered on time there you go there
you go can we get it on timer six months
we're not doing it it holds up six
months we're gonna get done this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Jade Washington Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America the question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services neighborly's home
service provider Network offers top
quality work and customer service by
trained reliable Home Service
professionals it's a great group of folk
visit neighborly.com to find experts in
your area and to schedule services today
all right today's question comes from
Michelle in California we're currently
in baby step two with a thousand dollar
emergency fund and still have debt to
pay off we're able to increase our
income and we will be paying off our
next debt of thirty eight hundred
dollars by September however I have this
Dreadful feeling that something bad will
happen to our family in our hometown in
Brazil
should that happen my husband and I will
be expected to cover the cost of the
funeral due to tradition can I pause
baby step two to increase my emergency
fund to five thousand dollars for what
right now is an unknown emergency what
an interesting question
um
I I would if you were here in real life
I'd ask you what do you think is going
to happen
in your hometown of Brazil like is
somebody ill is somebody on their death
bed I have questions do gangs run the
town well in Brazil you don't know
depends on if they're in those streets
of Rio or not now I have no idea I don't
know
you know what I think I think if any of
that was true she would have mentioned
it I think so I think this woman is a
worry wart I think she's a worry wart
too and my answer is no I would not
increase your emergency fund to 5 000.
not for vague distant possible Dreadful
feelings yeah now if something if you
did have an emergency if somebody
tangible thing yeah it's real something
real popped up there's a funeral cost my
mom has stage four cancer and they have
given her two months to live yes
different positive known that she would
have said she would have said it I yeah
and we don't know like is this her
in-laws is this it's a vague Dreadful
feeling yeah if it was specific there
would be something going on yeah but
this is a vague Dreadful this is a worry
wart this is a worry wart no my answer
is no
no don't don't stop the baby steps keep
going and like Dave said if something
actually happens and it's an actual uh
storm you'll work you'll work it out
you'll do it yeah you stop everything
and you'll pile up cash and you'll work
it out yeah but I you know it's like uh
there's a lot of stuff going on in the
economy I'm afraid I'm going to lose my
job yeah I mean why did they tell you at
your job they're laying people off no I
just have this feeling I have a feeling
no way you just stop your worry Warden
or they laid off 10 people last week and
they told me I'm probably next that's
different yeah that's different reason
yeah then we go oh okay you have a more
than 50 probability of losing your job
you don't need to be working the baby
steps you need to stop pile up cash and
get ready for the storm it's coming
people they close schools Tuesday
because on Monday they said there might
be tornadoes and that the skies are blue
yeah yeah I mean give me a break that's
the way the world here in Tennessee oh I
know I know I said that one day and then
tornadoes did hit and so I got totally I
got totally trashed by the weather Nazi
people they were so mad at me when I'm
missing my family
oh I won't mention which child is a
weather is a weather worry wart that's
look look tornadoes are nothing to play
with because they come suddenly yeah but
and they sell them that is true that is
true so you know that's just like you're
gonna it's bright blue skies outside
today if there's one coming tomorrow
yeah you know we'll make decisions
tomorrow okay we're not gonna make
decisions today yeah I don't do vague
Dreadful feelings okay so there we go
it's not it's just a bad idea it's not a
way to live your life open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Lisa is in Cape Coral Florida hi
Lisa welcome to the Ramsey Show
thanks for having me sure what's up
so I am wondering if it is all right to
give my friend some money for
um help just taking care of her and her
kids they had a house that collapsed
last month my problem is that I am seven
hundred thousand dollars in debt with a
baby on the way 700
000 yes I'm a veterinarian I have over
400 of that is in student loans and then
250 is my house and then other loans and
girl your house has collapsed your house
has collapsed too
but because I am working three jobs I do
make an extra six thousand a month to go
towards my debt slash the baby on the
way you're broke but yeah yeah I'm just
trying to break can I do it again no
it's unethical yeah
Only the Strong can help the weak you
got to take three people can't feed
hungry people
you gotta get yourself straightened out
so the next time something comes up
you're able and you're a broke
veterinarian yeah you're and you're
saying words like extra six thousand
it's not extra until that debt's paid
off that's got it it's earmarked 100 up
to next to 700 it falls over real fast
that's six thousand going towards 700 is
just tough
yep that's what I originally had said
but I wanted to get a double check and
I've been listening to you for a couple
weeks I'm like well Dave Ramsey said no
you should not then I guess no I want
you to be compassionate I want you to be
loving and if you want to go over there
and help her physically do some things
or something a little bit that's all
okay but uh when you're broke you're
broke are you uh you said you got you've
said you've got a baby on the way and
all this are you single mom
uh no it's me and my boyfriend okay okay
seven hundred thousand wow
that's yep how's it going
okay not bad okay good good good okay
yeah to answer your question is how
generosity has to come from Surplus
uh the only exception that we have to
that is for people or people of Faith
Who tie the
give a tenth of their income Jewish
tradition Christian tradition and that
comes off the top before you do anything
but in terms of helping miscellaneous
folk out there
um that's a wonderful thing to do and to
be able to do but you just simply can't
do it when you're broke but you made a
good point there's other things she can
do to help that are not Financial yeah
I'm sure you support her emotionally
when she's going through all that and
she's your friend you care about her or
you know but you know we don't have to
do a GoFundMe to prove our love that is
true
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Allen is with us
in Los Angeles hi Alan how are you
hi guys nice to talk to you better than
we deserve man what's up
so I came in to two thousand dollars
and I want to know if I should pay down
my student loan which I owe twenty
thousand or if I should use that money
to get an Appraiser's license so that I
can do that part-time on top of my
full-time job and on top of my part-time
job
why does it take two thousand dollars to
get an Appraiser's license in California
uh yes exactly it's a thousand for the
license I'm going to buy a new computer
website so it would be around maybe
under two thousand but around that much
oh so you don't have any customers
uh no not at the moment no so you would
be a brand new appraiser looking for
business
yes
in a slow economy
uh what was something I will do
part-time well they charge for what they
charge for residential appraisals out
there
uh uh 600 700 is there a shortage of
appraisers
yes a lot of them are green out of the
market yes and I know that for a fact
are they getting out of the market
because there's not enough work
yeah why why does it make you excited to
get in
there's something I can do part-time and
I like doing nothing you can't do it
part-time if you don't have any
appraisals to do
uh everybody's getting out of the
business why are they getting out of the
business dude
yeah business is slow
okay that's why they're getting out of
the business so I want you to call five
real estate agents that you know or
don't know and ask them
if you should get into the appraisal
business right now and would they send
you their appraisals
hmm
and uh then that'll kind of give you a
hint that you're not supposed to do this
right now
you're like doing Field of Dreams if I
build it they will come and maybe not
well everybody else who built
them yeah this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
folks you know that sinking feeling when
you make an offer on a house you love
and then you hear there's another offer
you need the Churchill Mortgage home
buyer Edge super fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
thank you for joining us America open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five at graces with us in
Dallas hi Grace welcome to the Ramsay
show
Hi how are y'all today right what's up
um I have well first thanks for um
taking my call I have a question about
moving coming up I am currently in baby
step number two and I know in October
I'm gonna either stay in my building or
move to a new one and either option is
going to cost me
um more money the cheapest would be to
stay in my building
um which I do not want to do but I would
sacrifice to do it
um but should I take the amount that I
know I'm gonna have to pay in increased
rent and then
um to should I take that amount out of
my monthly gazelle amount that I'm
putting towards my card or should I take
that out of the emergency fund none of
the above
take it out of your budget when it
actually happens
got it yeah okay if you move to another
building is it cheaper
the rent would be cheaper but the move
would cost me about sixteen hundred
dollars and also cleaning how much would
you say how much would you save on rent
um maybe
200 to 150 a month
okay and it's a better situation
no if I
was somewhere cheaper so even though I'd
be spending 1600 an entire moving cost I
would be saving a 150 to 200 a month in
rent which means you would break even
yeah and it it would be slightly a
better situation just not a safer
situation right now you would break even
Why move Why move if you don't like if
it's not a better situation and you all
you do is break even
so if you're spending two hundred
dollars and you spend you spend two
thousand to do that over 12 months you
you didn't you're saving 200 but you
spent 2 000 that's a break even
yeah okay so stay stay and put the
higher rent in your budget am I missing
something Jake I don't think so
um when do you plan to be out of debt
um if I can keep up the pace that I'm
doing now
um with the moving costs like the lower
living costs we're staying in my
building you don't have moving costs if
you don't move yeah if you stay in your
building you get to pocket that 1600.
you know what I meant was even if I
calculated
you're right I said moving costs but it
was my higher rent so my rent will
probably go up maybe a hundred dollars
if I stay here so even with that 100
increase
I would be paying I would still be able
to finish by April
good what do you make
um I recently just got a promotion so
starting April or not not April what
Monday and June 30th I will be making 70
40. 70 400.
good and how much debt do you have
um 16 200. good job on one card good job
you're pushing it right through well
done and you're gonna be done by April
and a hundred dollars doesn't kill you
if you're making 70 grand
okay cool slows it down by 100 between
now and April it slows it down 600 bucks
700 bucks
okay and I can make up for that and over
time and um
just like that yeah exactly and you're
still going to be out by April so yeah
no it definitely doesn't make sense to
do the move to save the yeah sure sit
right where you are and pay the higher
rent you're gonna be better off and
you're moving anyway in a year she
thinks so there you go
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Matt is in
Charlotte North Carolina hi Matt how are
you
hey how are you all great man how can we
help
yes my wife and I
um got married about a month ago and we
just found out this week that she's
pregnant wow congratulations
a lot of Big Life Changes going on
really happening all at once um so we're
really happy and excited but uh we were
uh following your baby steps we were on
step 3B but we were wanting your input
on on how we should uh prepare for the
child coming and you know do we halt 3B
and save or you know we we just wanted
your inputs uh so you've got you're on
go ahead
well we both can work and um you know
we've been saving uh as as singles and
then it's a married couple now for a
down payment on a home but obviously
with the child coming that would
potentially change things as far as our
priorities so yeah it could if you were
on baby step two for sure I'd be like
hold it you know or if you didn't have
three to six months of savings I'd be
like hold it pilot cash how much do you
have saved
um so yeah we are debt free on fully
funded emergency fund and then we've got
about 40 minutes
uh six months that's great okay what's
your household and then
um the gross is about a hundred and
eleven and then I guess so Matt let's
try this three let's try this keep
saving like a crazy person
into baby step 3B
and b stands for baby
if you need it if you need it but you
probably don't need it because I'm
guessing that you have health insurance
coverage labor and delivery right
and you've got enough to cover your
deductible what's your deductible
um for the family at six thousand okay
for labor delivery is that going to
apply
well I don't mean it's specific need to
find out today call your call your HR
people let's talk about health insurance
find out what coverage you've got for
her as an individual yeah and then start
planning it
and saying okay all right that so three
let's pretend you got 5K out of pocket
and the rest of it's covered okay it so
here's your plan your 3B just got
diminished by 5K when the event actually
occurs so we're going to pile up cash
pile up cash pile up cash mama and baby
come home from the hospital glorious
event we write a 5 000 check and we're
back on game
I see and you just and you just have a
little bit less in your 3B uh and uh we
don't buy a house while Mama's pregnant
that's just life advice yeah it didn't
it didn't stop your plan because you
were saving to begin with and if you had
said well we plan on buying a house in
the next couple of months we'd probably
tell you no no chill on that no no no no
no no no we don't move pregnant ladies
not not unless there's an emergency
not it does not does not the recipe for
fun you make different choices and
they're bad ones no no just wait just
wait till baby when everybody comes home
and everybody's all right probably this
time next year we're looking at houses
okay that's what I would do if I were in
your shoes I think you did it man that's
awesome congratulations that is
wonderful life's about to change it's
wonderful very cool good ways Michael is
with us Michael is in Indianapolis hey
Michael how are you hey thanks for
taking my call doing well how are you
better than I deserve what's up
so me and my wife were 23 years old we
just got done paying off 27 000 of uh
student loan debt in nine months way to
go um thank you we're both teachers and
today uh we went to the bank and we
wanted to start a savings account in
order to start saving up for a home and
I had a conversation with the mortgage
guy at the bank and he told me that in
order for me to get a mortgage through
the bank I have to go into debt to build
a credit score yeah well he's an idiot
yeah
so I mean actually the bank is an idiot
they may require that because some some
people don't know some mortgage
companies include especially Bankers
don't know how to do mortgages on on
manual underwriting but if you just call
Churchill Mortgage they can help you do
on on what's called manual underwriting
which is if you have a zero credit score
you can get the exact same premium rate
that is if you have a high credit score
that's right
perfect well that was my question
because that's our next step is
definitely buying a home yeah yeah don't
ask a banker about financial stuff I
think he knew that that Banker was
tripping I think I could tell it in his
voice and I told him that we followed
Dave Ramsey and he was like well the
problem with that and then I was like
okay I gotta go yeah good job Michael
the problem with that is he tells me not
to do business with people like you as
soon as that
oh good good instincts one more reason
to love Banks
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today if you're ready to buy
your first home in this market it's not
because of luck it's because you've been
putting in the work you've been kicking
butt you've been budgeting you've been
saving and we're fired up for you we
don't want your hard work to go to waste
buying a home is the biggest purchase
you'll ever make so the last thing you
need to do is fly solo or work with some
kind of brand new sweet little real
estate agent that doesn't know what the
flip they're doing even if it's your
Aunt Susan I know she's a nice lady but
you should leave this up to an agent
who's good enough you need great
a Ramsey trusted agent is a great agent
they set you up for Success before after
the closing day during the closing find
the right house keeping you on track
with your goals and making sure you're
confident in your decision Ramsay
trusted Pros get our stamp of approval
because we know they work hard to serve
you not to pad their paycheck
you've worked too hard to buy your first
home with anyone but the best find a
Ramsey trusted real estate agent by
going to ramseysolutions.com agent
ramseysolutions.com
agent Mary is with us in Tampa hi Mary
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey thanks for taking my call Dave sure
what's up
so um I don't know where I should start
but um I've got over 85 000 with a debt
with my husband
um that we've incurred over probably the
last 15 years been having trouble paying
it off
um so we're married for now I'm not sure
how much longer because I talked to a
lawyer uh he calls him a schmuck
basically
um I've got a lawyer or your husband
the lawyer calls my husband a schmuck oh
that's nice I know isn't that beautiful
um I have a high school graduate that's
going to college and
I have a special we have a special niece
daughter who's 13 years old
um and I didn't work for like eight
years but I went back about seven years
ago and I worked my way up
um and I'm making about 75 000 right now
and he's finally um he had his own
business not doing anything
um lost our butts trying to sell our
house
um and you know using our profits to pay
off all the debt from from his business
but he finally he has a job a stable job
in the past year and a half
um so I'm trying to figure out how to
pay off or how we're supposed to pay off
this debt um and
and gracefully exit out of the marriage
we had to we're renting it now because
we sold we sold our house let me stop
you a second okay
um how long have you been married
um 17 18 years I'm sorry longer than
that 24. my bad 24 years yeah last track
why is your marriage over
it's been mentally checked out for
some time for many many years he worked
a lot
um worked a lot trying to make money
still in the beginning and eventually
nothing and then the lockdown hit and we
were able to stop some some of the pain
of not having money but I've been
working so
um and a year ago he told me he had a
relationship with someone and so that's
basically Mark I was I was waiting for
the schmuck party have you filed yet
have you filed for the divorce yet no no
I just I I just I can't afford to like I
don't know I'm in Tampa things are just
everything's ridiculously expensive and
I can't I've been looking to see you
know what what my options are but I
can't afford to like live alone right
now
didn't you say you made 75 000 a year
I do people make 75 000 a year live up
by themselves all the time in Tampa
that's a I know kind of average
they don't live in your neighbor
but they live I already lived out
of the neighborhood we live on the
French so to save money because rents
were about a thousand dollars more where
we were at yeah
when you talk to your lawyer when you
talk to your lawyer about this have you
done any research to find out what the
cost is
what might happen with your debt
that sort of thing I don't know yeah I
don't know what happens with the gut and
I'm not sure if I remember asking him
about the debt
um I just know that everything else is
no fault so basically we just kind of
walk away it's not like one of us makes
more than the other person right now
um and she she wants my husband wants to
consolidate the debt um or maybe what
kind of debt do you have on it
so it's 85 000 in credit card debt we
paid off our HELOC and all this other
stuff we had when we sold our house so
we were pretty much left with nothing
after we filled our house
okay and I guess all the credit card
debt is in both of your names
yeah the one cards in his and tour in
mine
but is it about half
yeah
the two that you have are about forty
two five
uh yeah 30 they're all 30 across the
board
and this is hard making the payments
okay so you're 75 000 a year single mom
that has 38 000 in credit card debt
after the divorce right and you have a
special needs child
yes and he would hypothetically be
paying child support
I don't know yeah
yeah for him yeah my other daughter's
gone now or she's 18 now yeah so
hypothetically you have child support in
the special needs child right
yes okay
and um so you're I'm sorry this is a
very sad situation it is
um but you're not
mathematically trapped
um
lots of people make 75 000 a year in the
Tampa area that if Thirty thirty eight
thousand dollars in credit card debt in
one kit
lots of people I know we really hope
that we have a lot of Health expenses
because my older daughter actually has a
more hold this his more health issues
than my younger daughter and my special
needs daughter they're both you actually
yeah so we're constantly running the
doctors doing surgeries doing different
things
car repairs and just the debt it just
you know that's not going to change
yeah
you're not stuck mathematically
you're not if you want to be you can
decide you are but the numbers you've
given us have not got you stuck in this
and uh if he's having Affairs and you're
going to end the marriage based on that
then you're going to have half of the
credit card debt
and you're going to have the care of a
child and you make seventy five thousand
dollars a year and you're going to go
rent an apartment
I think I think what I'm hearing is
you've never been in a situation where
money is managing where money is being
managed effectively right and now you're
about to go off on your own and you
don't have the confidence of knowing
I can take the 75 000 a year and I can
manage it effectively it can be because
it's never been enough before right so
you don't know like inside your body you
don't know that this is going to be
enough that I'm going to be able to take
care of my kids that I'm going to be
able to pay the bills and then I'm going
to be able to pay the debt up you don't
know that that's I mean you understand
that the story you told us has you all
mathematically in with him working and
earning you working and earning in the
best place you've been in probably a
decade mathematically you're in the best
place
relationally obviously relationally
obviously you're not in the best place
she doesn't feel that she doesn't you
don't have any respect for him because
he didn't make any money during this
time he's a schmuck because he slept
around on you
um and so relationally you got those
things to overcome for this marriage to
survive if it's going to survive but
mathematically you're in the best place
you've ever been because you know with
his income if you if the marriage
survived with his income and your income
if you both decide to manage money
together you could clean this mess up
rather quickly
but we just resigned our lease that's
2300 I mean the next
where we're at that's like the cheapest
that we could get so we just renewed our
leaders it doesn't sound like someone
that's filing for divorce to me
who's filing for divorce that re-signs a
new lease
for a year well I don't know I don't I
just I don't either who does that too
much going on mental I don't know I
think you just made a choice
yeah yeah she was like I have no choice
yeah I have no choice
but you felt like you had no choice but
you're taking your choices away but if
you want to be stuck out yeah you know
you can be stuck if you want to be but
you're not stuck
so um you know I I think that you guys
could sit down with a good marriage
counselor and invest some time and
energy into this 25-year marriage and
give this a shot since you just signed a
one-year lease I kind of think you want
to do that
deep down and by the way if you ask a
divorce attorney if you're supposed to
get a divorce a hundred percent of the
time they say yes
it's like asking a dog if it's hungry
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade wash
all Ramsay personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
you your life your money your career
your relationships triple eight eight
two five five two two five
Tiffany starts off this hour hi Tiffany
how are you
I am thank you so much for taking my
call I'm sorry I'm a little nervous it's
okay what's up
um I'm an office manager for a small
construction company and
um one of the owners out of the two has
been using the secret credit card and
purchasing a lot of purchase personal
stuff with it and then using the
company's checking to pay off the
balance each month I'm just kind of
curious is it only
um morally wrong if I don't say anything
to the owner other owner or um
is it not my um none of my business to
be passing information along
so let me help you with how you answer a
business ethics question
treat other people
like you'd want to be treated
so reverse it
you own a construction company and you
have an employee
who knows that there is a thief
inside the business
what would you expect that employee to
do ethically
um definitely tell me that my concern is
I feel like if I say something I'll lose
my job but if I don't say something I
don't say something and I found out and
you worked for me I would fire you
okay for not telling me why why would
you lose your job foretelling
the other guy's got more power than the
other than the guy she's telling they're
they're equal Partners but um one is
kind of Silent he's he's
kind of but um yeah
um I just the lion is this thief and the
wimp
is the guy losing the money
oh you need to get out of there don't
you
yeah I just started listening to you
guys about a week ago and um I'm finally
a baby step one I've got 98 000 in debt
how old are you
uh 33. what do you make oh
uh currently 56 with um this job and I
just got a part-time job what do you
make there at the thief place
50. okay and how long have you been
there
three years okay sometimes doing the
right thing is painful in the short term
it is never painful in the long term
one hundred percent of the time that you
don't take care of this it's going to
cause you problems later
well the the weak leader that this other
guy is basically stealing money do you
think there's a chance that he'll just
be like uh yeah big deal do you think
that he won't care
I think he'll blame me for not I guess
watching more closely and not giving
them a heads up I mean everything else
has been going on
um
it's just gotten progressively worse
over the past and what I asked I asked
how long he's been stealing
uh probably since I started which is how
long
about three years
um but it hasn't been to this level like
um
I stealing has levels but at no point is
it okay
so you're concerned because you've
noticed this for three years and you
haven't said anything but now you're
like I gotta say something and you're
afraid that the other guy's gonna go hey
why didn't you say something sooner
Tiffany you're gonna lose your job
yeah that's what I used to look for a
job I'm gonna lose it either way I need
to go yeah you're gonna go you're gonna
lose your job because you didn't take
care of this when you should have
the first time you saw it you should
have walked in his office the other
guy's office and said look I don't know
what to do with this information but if
the roles were reversed I would want to
know and I'm going to leave the
information with you to do with what you
want but it's not going to be on me I'm
not keeping secrets for thieves
I went to leave a year ago and I figured
that once nonetheless that
honey this is on your watch
okay you have to report the thief and
you have to look for a job
number one even if they want to keep you
you don't want to work there anymore
that's true
okay this is a messed up toxic
environment yeah
a strong thief and a weak need partner
this is not and you're stuck in the
middle and didn't know what to do and
therefore didn't do the right thing yeah
that's a warning sign when when you're
in a situation like that and you can't
you don't feel you'll be supported or if
for doing the right thing that's a
problem too yeah it's not even even if
the guy even if they rise up and have a
big Clash over it and the guy we're
calling the weak leader is you're going
to stand up to the other guy surprise he
stood up okay we're all surprised we're
all shocked uh but even then you're not
going to come out of this you've known
this for three years
you don't come out looking good because
you didn't bring it up earlier yeah it
makes it look like you're part of it
yeah that's what I was concerned that I
look like the
movies and hiding it is not going to fix
that
okay so go get a job this week walk in
and tell the guy I should have told you
three years ago I'm sorry I didn't I
goofed I let you down I'm out of here
I'm not gonna work in a place like this
this guy's stealing from you
go take your new job a personal question
um I do have two interviews this week
but it's significantly like ten dollars
less an hour do I just suck it up and
take them and work multiple jobs until I
find something yep get something yep
something's better than nothing and then
otherwise every day you're going in
there you are a liar
oh okay you can't be that that's not who
you are that's why you called us because
it's tearing your guts yeah it's eating
you up
you're not that person you're not that
person and you can't anxiety pills for
the past year hello yeah hello and John
and John Maxwell John deloney says
anxiety is a fire alarm warning you that
there's a problem well guess what
there's a problem of course you're going
to have anxiety in a situation where
you're protecting a thief and you're not
a thief and you're not a liar by Nature
of course you're going to have anxiety
so hey we're going to save you a bunch
of money we're getting rid of your
anxiety pills because we're gonna do
this job you're going to feel so much
better Tiffany when you get out of there
you're gonna feel like you're gonna Feel
clean like you took a shower
I'm just concerned too about like
financially
and monthly fund and as aren't so much
debt well you've got these jobs lined up
you don't have a choice
okay you're about to get fired
as soon as they find this they're going
to blame it on you if you don't bring it
up
because Mr lion that's the thief is
going to have a story somehow well
Tiffany's known about it we all thought
it was all okay what's your problem well
the problem is you're a freaking Thief
that's my problem but nobody stands up
to this guy so you got to get out of
there girl this is bad news and next
time you're presented with an Ethics
problem don't wait three years to fix it
and chew on anxiety pills and wonder why
you got anxiety
you step into the ethic stuff face up
so team member at Ramsey knows another
team member stealing doesn't tell me I
discover it they're both gone
I'm not a big old meanie but I can't
trust either one of them and trust is an
essential part of a relationship this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
guarantee and shipping is always free
see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
forty percent off selected products
visit blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
Jade wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today high school graduation
season winding down but plenty of
sophomores and juniors who will be
getting their diplomas are still
uncertain about their future they're
asking like what am I supposed to do
with the rest of my life
what should my major be should I really
get a degree in German polka history if
that sounds like a high schooler in your
life here's some good news with the new
get clear assessment for students
they don't have to walk this road alone
we took our popular assessment for
adults and made the questions more
relatable to students who are about to
take the next step into entrepreneurship
College trades wherever they're called
they're going to answer a few questions
and minutes later they'll get a customer
Report with clear answers that truly
drives them their top strengths and
their possible careers that will be a
great fit for them give them the gift of
confidence of knowing what they were
made to do because that's the kind of
gift that will last a lifetime order the
get clear assessment for students today
ramsesolutions.com get to clear
you know Jade I was going through that
just now and I was remembering a guy
that's a friend of mine
he's an old guy my age
he might be slightly younger but he's
right around my age and uh many years
ago he was a photographer
and
um is gifted
and this this would this get clear
assessment would reveal that he was
gifted at his ability to see things they
call it spatial orientation he can see
things in 3D in his mind
uh so uh he was a gun guy and he loved
guns and he started building a gun
and uh he built I ended up building a
gun that became world famous and opening
a gun company selling that comp that gun
worldwide for millions and millions and
millions of dollars and sold the company
for millions and millions or millions of
dollars all off of this one set of gifts
now he obviously learned business he did
a lot of other things sales you know all
that but in terms of actually he can he
had a a Tradesman type gift that he
could see the engineering of that never
had formal engineering training does not
have an engineering degree but turn that
that so getting clear on what your gifts
are is a big deal it is a big deal
it can it can lead it can keep you from
going and getting a degree in exactly
the wrong thing and spending 200 000
doing it Ellie and it can show you all
of the ways that your skill set can be
used to earn money yeah as opposed to
just drilling down on one type one job
now what was interesting about his story
was he was a very good photographer
using that exact same special gift but
that was not his passion I mean he used
that same ability to see things in 3D
that spatial orientation to
see a gun yeah you know and then went to
the machine shop and built one not an
engineer not a machinist but knew how
knew what he wanted and kept working
until he got it to do what he wanted it
to do and uh and it's you know it's a
phenomenal piece of equipment that's
cool and has saved lives all over the
world in in the military it's a it's
amazing so yeah but it all comes back
from you know recognizing your Genius
you know and stepping into it Robert is
in West Palm Florida hi Robert welcome
to the Ramsay show
good afternoon Dave and Jake so I just
had a question about um
thousand student loans and we're looking
to possibly get out of our house sell
the house use the difference after
um we pay off the rest of the house and
pay off the student loans and then go
into putting into a down payment into a
new house and just kind of are back and
forth and want to run through some
numbers and see if it's the right idea
or if we should try and stick it out
okay so the price home that your current
home would sell for how much
around 400 000. and if you did all this
and bought another house what would the
value of that home be
uh we're looking somewhere between 4 50
and 5. so you would move up in house
we have two young kids and we only have
the house we have now ones is only so
you're thinking of moving up in-house
anyway and you're trying to use the
student loan as an excuse
me uh not necessarily it was just
something that we we could do cross
cross house in about the same size house
about around the same amount around that
400 between 450 amount somewhere around
that price but just mostly to pay off
either the whole student loan or a chunk
of good shoes you don't like your
current house
no we do
really
yeah I mean we do it's why we've gone
back and forth because we could stick it
out in the house for another because I
think we have about four years for both
of ours to be paid off what's your
income student loans what's your income
um about 85 to 90 net per year between
the both of us okay so if you sell your
current house
and you buy a home
slightly more expensive
and pay off a hundred and ten thousand
dollars worth of student loan debt out
of the equity from the sale therefore
have less of a down payment
by a hundred and ten thousand on the
next house
did I get the story right
yes if you do that it's the same thing
as just refinancing your house and
paying off a student loan with a
mortgage
okay so you think it's probably that's
not it's exactly this do you understand
that's exactly the same thing
you moved your student loan to a
mortgage
yeah and I think that's where we're
looking at it because instead of paying
interest on a student loan is that it
would be paying towards equity in a new
house to where it was more paying
towards ourselves you already have a
house
yes so that does not mathematically hold
water
okay so if you didn't have a house and
this got you a house then you would say
we'd be building Equity but if you have
a 400 000 house that's building Equity
or you have a 450 000 house building
Equity they're both building Equity
regardless of the mortgage
all you did was put the more the student
loan on a mortgage that's all you did in
this scenario
so you could either refinance the
current house if you like it and do the
same thing
okay yeah because we refinanced on the
house and got it down to about three
percent
um so that's why we're thinking maybe we
should just stick with the house that
we're in now
um because like I said I think it's
about four years max if we don't that's
just based off of normal pay what's your
household income again 90k 85 to 90k
yeah okay yeah you're probably three
years if you really bear down on it with
beans and rice
what do you do for a living
uh I'm an insurance adjuster okay
all right so what I'm trying to
get you to see is I want you to rethink
your process of decision making
because effectually what you did was you
borrowed on a mortgage to pay off your
student loans
as if you had refinanced your current
residence in your scenario
and when I Reef frame that and pointed
that out to you I'm still not 100 sure
you got it
you know I understand what you're saying
you're saying it's almost moving you're
just moving yeah you truly are using the
house move as an excuse to refinance
those student loan into a mortgage
yes and I and I I understand where
that's why we are going back and forth
and we've had this bleeding towards the
not not moving and just thinking I don't
think I don't really need to go back and
forth don't do that
that's what I was trying to tell you
okay don't do that so you would not we
would not suggest that you go refinance
your home and use the money to pay off
your student loans we would tell you to
pay off your student loans and we would
therefore not tell you to do effectually
the same thing with a move
um now if you told me you were going to
move to a 200 000 house from a four
hundred thousand dollar house and free
up a hundred and ten thousand to pay on
the student loans and you wanted to make
that sacrifice to get out of debt now
I'd have to think about do I really want
to do that or not yeah that's not bad
but that's a pretty deep cut and I
usually sell my home to get out of debt
as my last resort but selling it with
what you're talking about you're not
there's no sacrifice involved as a
matter of fact it's quite the opposite
you're going up yeah
going up at home yeah so you're not
sacrificing at all
a matter of fact you're you're you know
you're trying to skip over getting the
student loan paid off and you don't get
to do that it's in there somewhere you
can always hide the P but it's under one
of those shells oh it's under there all
right
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hollow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
personality is my co-host today Brent is
in Columbia South Carolina Hi Brent
welcome to the Ramsay show
it's a pleasure to be on here sir how
you doing today honored to have you how
can we help
oh so I I'm going through a little bit
of a dark Valley just get a little
backstory real quick
um I uh
I am uh born again Christian I just gave
my life to the Lord about eight months
ago wow very cool and in yeah I I was in
a very very bad time uh my life my old
lifestyle you know either could have in
the ended me a bed or in prison so uh
and I wanted to make a change and plus
um unfortunately it cost me my marriage
uh but I'm on the right path to at least
make myself better and hope and pray
that you know God can answer a couple
prayers for me and reconcile my marriage
but I um
I am
on a business venture uh it's an
untapped Market that nobody has touched
before and
I'm just trying to make sure that I
am going to be able to with my income
right now being able to also pay my uh
my my bills that I got to pay plus be
able to uh pay for all the patent stuff
that I got to do my patents already in
the process right now but I have to get
that there's stuff that you got to pay
because we all know patents don't aren't
just something that you pay for right on
the spot you have to pay for it over
time so I'm just trying to make sure
that my patent uh the money that I have
for my patent is there when it's needed
and then also be able to pay for my
bills and also be able to make sure that
I'm able to do what I need to do to
sustain my living while I'm out on the
road
okay so you have a job
yes then you make what
I make I'm on track right now to make
roughly about eighty one eighty two
thousand dollars this year and out on
the road is with your job
yes I'm a truck driver for a living oh
okay all right
and um
all right so
basically you want to make sure that
you're having the money to maintain your
lifestyle but also start this business
and be productive with it what have you
been told you'll need for the patent
money-wise how much money
my patent lawyer said that throughout
the span of the next year or so I'm
looking at probably close to about
fifteen to twenty thousand dollars
okay so you have a a patent lawyer in
South Carolina that you're working with
yes okay
and um this is an attorney and a law
firm
that was recommended in a building that
you went and sat with
yes my uh my my personal uh attorney
recommended me to this guy okay good
good because in the world that you're
dabbling in there are a bunch of
shysters and I was trying to make sure
you didn't get hooked up with one there
are companies that claim that they can
get you a patent and they'll claim they
get you uh distribution and help you
with prototypes and all this stuff and
uh they'll take ten thousand dollars
from you up front and you'd never get
anything
those are out there there's a bunch of
those out there okay so stay away from
that kind of a thing so it sounds like
you've got an attorney though that's on
the up and up so I'm fine with that and
then you do have to go it sounds like
you're building a physical product so
you're going to get a prototype and you
have to think about who's going to buy
it and how you're going to get it to
manufacture or are you going to sell the
whole kit and caboodle off of the
Prototype and walk away
you know you got to decide your approach
after that because it's getting the
patent is just the very first step
um
and I've already I've already got the
Prototype I'm actually in the process of
building uh I've got a set you know
designed everything I've already built
one kit and I am
uh this weekend actually I start
production on building the the rest of
the kits from the materials that I have
right now all this stuff will be of
course branded
um I have my own branding my own
business name uh so it will and I make
everything in-house
um
the only thing I don't make in-house is
one of the components that I have to
actually order who's buying this
who's the customer uh so
uh truck drivers
and so how are you going to get how are
you going to get the information of them
so that they buy it
Okay so
I have a background in social media
marketing I actually used to have a uh a
huge following on uh on social media uh
but when I gave my life to Florida I got
rid of everything
um and I focused solely on just trying
to help people's businesses grow like
they're following you on social media
what was the what was the reason they
were following you that merger hell
racing or they liked something else you
were doing
well it was because of my old lifestyle
um I I don't want to get too much into
it because he that be in Christ is a new
creature and I don't even feel like I'm
talking about the same person anymore
you know so
um I
was a lot of people liked it because
I was telling people the truth about
something
and I still stand firm to a lot of it
but it's no longer who I am that's how I
just branched off of it so okay all
right I'm just trying to yeah without
getting too far in I'm just trying to
figure out what's going on good good
okay
you got away to sell it you got a way to
produce your first sets what is your
question
so my um with me and my separation and
everything when I when all this happened
I pretty much invested as much money as
I could possibly invest into
uh building myself up in my marriage and
stuff like that and I practically spent
way too much money
um me and my wife sold our house
um fortunately we were able to uh we had
a place that we could go to and it
didn't cost us anything
um but we basically this a lot of that
money was spent to go to go forward in
our life but at the same time there was
also a lot of it that was blown and I
pretty much had to look at my account
one day and basically just say oh my
goodness like a hundred thousand dollars
was spent in a year yeah how can we help
you today
so
I'm sure I'm building everything up my
emergency funds and everything I just
want to make sure from someone who is
actually business savvy how I can make
sure that I'm having everything in the
right spot that it needs to be in so
that I can tackle this business venture
that I'm doing and be as successful as I
possibly can
okay as far as money goes right all
right so what I would do is tell you it
sounds like you probably have already
done this but the basics are you open a
separate business account
to do the business out of the new patent
deal okay the only money you put into
that account are is money that comes
from sales
the only money you take out of that are
business expenses and you take care of
your household budget off of your truck
driving income
okay I don't want you eating out of the
business right now I want all the money
that goes in all the money that goes out
the difference is called profit so if
you put ten thousand dollars in there
because a whole bunch of people order
some of these with your social media
skills and you uh you and you go and
order some materials for six thousand
dollars the money that's left is four
thousand dollars that's called profit
okay and so you just run everything
completely separate don't mix your
grocery money into your business account
you follow me
because that'll give you clear pictures
on how the business is doing and what's
going on and if you're feeding the
business or the business is feeding you
because sometimes in a small situation
like this where people are passionate
like you are they can throw money into
the project and and they look up later
like you looked up and realized a
hundred thousand dollars is gone you'll
look up and realize God I just put 80
000 bucks in this I did not mean to do
that over the last two years and um
without making a profit because and but
if you've got this account that's either
getting squeezed or flush it's talking
to you about how the business is doing
if it's squeezed or not you know you're
not selling enough you're paying too
much for your materials whatever it is
if it's squeezed you're looking for the
what's causing the problem if it's flush
it means hey we got things going we got
good sales going here we all we you know
we got a production problem maybe we
have trouble producing the items fast
enough but um keep it completely
separate like you're running it for
someone else
and then that that way that simple
checking account will do that if you
pull money out of that business or at
the end of the year if there's money
left in that account it's going to be
taxable
and so set aside a fourth of anything
you pull out to get ready for taxes on
that business and you may want to get a
CPA to help you make sure you're doing
that right
[Music]
foreign
13 4 the soul of the sluggard craves and
gets nothing
while the soul of the diligent is richly
supplied
Tim Allen said if you don't decide where
you're going life will decide for you
[Music]
Pat's with us in South Bend Indiana hi
Pat welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave it's a real pleasure to speak
with you today you too what's up
for several years now
I never thought much about that money I
just kind of considered it an emergency
fund for medical stuff well I looked I
looked at it a couple weeks ago when
it's up to about twenty thousand dollars
so um the account offers investment
options but I haven't looked at them
because it kind of seems opposite to the
purpose of an emergency fund right but
it's not an emergency fund though you
have an emergency fund don't you
I do yeah is it is that in a good
savings account
money market
yeah yeah that's fine okay yeah my HSA
is 100 invested in mutual funds
okay so that was my question should I
consider investing at least a portion of
that money now that there's
more in there than I would ever need
immediately I guess the exception is do
you have an oncoming known medical event
I don't
um not not as of now
the uh kind of blessed with good health
so far I I don't spend very much money
on health care so you know there's
there's more money in there than what I
see an immediate need for so Dave you
fully invest your HSA because I won't be
touching it yeah I I save out enough for
the deductible yeah and then that's the
rest that'd be fun too you know if you
said okay my deductible's 5K so I'm
going to invest 15 in your case that
that'd be a good plan too
um I've got a lot of liquid cash so in
my particular situation so I the
likelihood of me tapping into that HSA
is very low unless I just wanted to pay
some medical bills with tax-free dollars
which is what the HSA saving the health
savings account allows you to do
um and right now instead what I have as
I approach 65 I'll be turning it into a
retirement account yeah which is very
great you know so it's just grown
tax-free it's like another 401K for me
because I've never used it so and so if
you're not using it invest it and so
Jade's right if you want to hold out the
the the deductible portion to be super
say if you could do that or if you have
a known medical event you say I got I'm
getting ready to have to come out of 10
grand well don't pop that in mutual
funds and then turn it up take it back
out that just leave that liquid but it's
a great vehicle if you don't yeah
exactly if you don't then let's use it
that way Matthew's in New York hi
Matthew welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thanks for having me sure what's
up just looking for looking for your
advice on how I should handle my
mortgage I'm 30 years old recently
married and my wife and I have about 250
000 on our mortgage and about 400k in
assets not including the house so I just
don't know how fast I should talk with a
mortgage and it's also at a very low
interest rate two and a half percent
what kind of assets
ah so a hundred thousand in retirement
and then of the remaining 300 000 about
150 in mutual funds and the remainder
are in stock like apple or Costco Tesla
real estate uh uh stocks okay so you got
300K in stocks and mutual funds
yes and they all have a 250 000 mortgage
yes
I'm getting I hate to tell you this so
the the 300K it's non-retirement money
no no I'm retiring money 100K additional
in retirement money I would pay off the
house
even though it's a two and a half
percent interest and I could get higher
Returns on like REITs and other other
stable stocks Matthew if the house was
paid for
would you go borrow 300K on it to invest
if you switch it around it's the same
thing
okay just it's tough for me to you know
pull that trigger because like you know
I've been investing since I was 18 years
old have you ever lived in a paid off
home before
uh no I lived at home until I was at 27.
I think that's why it's hard for you I
think that's why it's hard because
you've never experienced that but when
you pay this home off you're gonna go oh
my gosh and you're gonna think back on
what we just said and you're gonna go
man that's absolutely true I would not
Bart now that I'm free I would not
borrow that money to do those
Investments let's walk this out a second
okay what's the house worth
houses what about 450 000. and what is
your household income now that you're
married uh right now it's about it's my
wife and I about 170k and I hope they
get up a little higher in the next
couple of years okay so you know average
200k over the next few years to see row
payments in the whole world
and you're how old now
I'm 30. okay and so you understand that
by the time you're 35 you're gonna have
a net worth over a million dollars
yeah that's my goal to get there you
know I mean with what we just outlined
you because if you take your old house
payment you've you've got that and
tremendous ability to cash flow you
start maxing out all 401ks and doing
additional investing because you like to
invest you told us that
um and if your new wife likes to invest
with your fabulous income and absolutely
no payments in the world see your most
powerful wealth building tool is not
borrowing on your house your most
powerful wealth building tool is your
income and when you're not paying it to
some stupid but Bank you can use it to
get rich my friend and that's what
you're in the process of doing so if I
were in your shoes I would do exactly
what Jade told me to do by the end of
the day I would be dead
free and I'd be running around Manhattan
like a wow man yelling I'm debt free and
or Queens are the Bronx or wherever you
are I mean you have to you have to admit
though Dave
that's a jarring that's a jarring for
people to say hey cash out your stocks
pay out your pay off your house
it's not as jarring as to the tune of
250 000 I mean that's not it's not as
jarring as taking a paid for house and
borrowing On It Best in stocks of course
it's the same thing I I
I accept that but I
I
hey we've always been known at Ramsey
for being weird we have
to say what yeah because he's been
taught to use the difference in his
mortgage rate and invest in you know
investing in apples we've made good
money on that yeah and uh but you're
basically saying I'm gonna risk my home
with my new bride to play stock market
boy
not doing it man yeah not doing it so
and you're you know all you gotta do is
reverse engineer these questions exactly
right and they tell you what to do
sometimes you're like no I would never
do that yeah it will effectually you are
so it says if if you keep that stock
tomorrow Matthew instead of paying it
off today it's as if you borrowed on
your home 250
000 to put it into the market and play
yeah well and he's gonna I mean he's
gonna how about a high risk maneuver
none of your math that you're doing
where you think that
um you're making all this money on your
borrowed money you've not entered any
mathematics to represent the risk that
you're taking that's right
well that's what everybody feels to
account for
yeah so perfect you know when you
mathematically adjust for risk it takes
a lot of the fun away
where you thought oh I'm so smart I
borrowed money at three or four and I'm
investing and I'm making 10 or 11 and
you feel smart but you didn't adjust for
taxes and you didn't adjust for risk and
when you adjust for those two things
mathematically it neutralizes the
advantages of Leverage
if you do the math properly
um because that you know all all things
have risk and debt every time you borrow
money it has risk the more debt the more
risk sometimes you've got such a small
amount of debt that it doesn't feel like
you have risk but a small amount still
represents risk it's just small
and big debt big risk I mean if you
borrowed take a 400 000 property and you
borrow 600 000 on it at 12 and now we
got big risk yeah you know and so it's
because you're over leveraged and that's
where you're setting yourself up Matthew
that's a really good question
congratulations on the new marriage I'm
not sure you're gonna do what Jade told
you to do but you should I just I just
think it's a boss move to live in a paid
for home can I just say that mathematics
is not in New York City okay hello I'm
with you there that's amazing putting
this hour in the books the booth dudes
are back together Austin Ben James
second Andrew the booth dudes did it
again
it's like a band reunion ah I'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]